au son des bâtons les marcheurs avalent
les mettre en rythme
la discipline prend ses origines loin
des bords de Loire plus au nord sur les
reliefs finlandais
et les skieurs de fonds l'été ne peuvent
pas s'entraîner puisque naturellement il
n'y a pas de neige donc il pratique et
la marche nordique qui est à peu près
une similitude avec la gestuelle du ski
de fond pour se lancer rien de plus
simple de bonne chaussure et des bâtons
nordiques bien sûr l'erreur du débutant
apprendre les mauvais gestes pour se
propulser vers l'avant marcher c'est
facile marcher des bateaux ça se trouve
ça se complique un peu donc ça demande
quand même un peu d'apprentissage et
pour avoir une gestuelle parfaite ça
demande de
au moins deux ans de pratique
encadré par des coachs qui corrigent
constamment qu'il faut faire des
exercices
de fédération se partagent l'activité
l'athlétisme pour la compétition et la
randonnée pour le loisir avec 5000
licenciés en région ce sport santé se
porte bien maintenant la discipline est
reconnue par les kinés par les médecins
par les cardiologues qui nous envoient
des gens à pathologie pour leur faire
travailler les muscles le cœur en
particulier ça entretient 80% des
muscles si on pratique bien la gestuelle
on respire mieux on s'oxygène mieux
le plaisir de l'activité physique qui
peut être malgré tout intense même si
c'est de la marche on peut pratiquer de
la marche nordique un peu comme de
l'athlétisme c'est-à-dire avec du
fractionné du cardio sur des distances
assez longues c'est hyper physique et le
challenge c'est quand même la technique
je pense que il faut être quand même
hyper concentré pour appliquer les bons
gestes donc c'est c'est un sport qui est
hyper complet autour de la discipline de
nouvelles activités se développent comme
le Nord Dick feet un mélange de fitness
et de cardio 4 3
du renforcement musculaire et les bâtons
ne sont jamais très loin
c'est pour activer le cardio le coeur la
circulation sanguine tout ça et puis
donc pareil en gardant donc c'est assez
marge nordique donc avec la boucle qui
font ici et l'engouement se confirme en
compétition à Tours la première course
10 km avait rassemblé 300 sportifs en
2021 cette année le nombre d'inscrits à
doublés
en solo ou en groupe la marche nordique
est un sport très féminin ce groupe
d'amis se retrouve chaque semaine à son
rythme
du sport parfois parce qu'on est à fond
et puis parfois on sait prendre aussi le
temps regarder les
oiseaux la nature
s'interroger sur un arbre c'est un peu
culturel aussi parfois nous allons dans
des villages moins intense que la course
à pied est plus dynamique que la
randonnée la discipline se pratique
partout de quoi encore séduire un large
public